and we'll stick with this game just for
a moment longer so let's see if Fabi
continues if he fights on
yeah
Magnus he's gonna be loving life
suddenly it looked so well more content
with life at the very least yeah because
uh the tournament which look like a
complete disaster is now
uh looking a lot more manageable and he
does have a you know a bit of a run-up
uh
five rounds to go a point on a and a
half behind the leader and and yeah it
looks like they're signing they're
signing score sheets here yeah probably
finally resigns unsurprising there
really wasn't very much to play for
anymore
yeah
nice finish for Magnus very efficient at
the end and yeah it looks like Magnus is
running he's in the last five rounds
he'll play three uh the Indian teenagers
so
it'll be fascinating to see how that
goes
yeah absolutely